we've got time to go through one example
uh there's lots of things that we do
with lines in 2D and we're going to have
a version of that in three dimensions so
uh how do we say for example find the
point of intersection between a pair of
lines that intersects you'll notice this
is 15a I have a sign for you 15b so um
that's why I've if you're wondering like
why did we go to skip skip that question
this is why I wanted to use it as an
example okay
um how do you normally find the point of
intersection between two lines if I gave
you two lines in two Dimensions what
would you do
let them equally yeah you would equate
them right now if I were to equate the
the lines are in this case what happens
well that's actually just for the sake
of it let's just write this out okay so
if I equate I would say all right here's
four eight three
plus Lambda uh one two one
and then the other line is seven six
five plus uh do you guys recognize the
name of that Greek letter over there
that's mu maybe you recognize it from
your um continuous random variables and
stuff like that it's it's used in there
for the for the mean so I've got six
four and five as this column Vector over
here okay
now what you've got here is we have
equated the vector equations of two
lines this is what we should do however
it turns out
um well this is a bit of a mess like
what do I do with this where do I even
begin what we want to do is we want to
convert these Vector equations of lines
into a version that makes it easier to
work with we want to separate these out
okay now you might not have encountered
this uh this language before but what we
actually want is the parametric
equations
of lines
so I'm going to separate this one
equation the vector equation of ions
which is really actually three equations
uh balled up together so can you see
there's an X equation just using the X
components do you see that so I would
write that as
uh actually sorry I've chosen a bad
color first let me just change that
something I haven't used like green okay
there we go so if I think about just the
X components what I'm getting is 4 plus
1 Lambda which is just Lambda that's
equal to what do you have on the right
hand side
very good that's the X equation right
when I look across the y components I'm
going to get uh eight plus two Lambda
equals what
okay
six six plus four mu very good and then
lastly if I look at the Z components I
get a third equation so it's going to be
three plus Lambda equals okay you get
the idea by now five plus five mu
now you're following along right you can
see there's two unknowns Lambda and mu
and I've got one
two
three equations
now this is kind of funny right I've got
more equations than I need I only need
two of these equations to solve uh
simultaneously right so being that I've
got three to choose from and I only need
two out of the three which ones would
you choose just have a look
yeah I I'm with you I think the first
one and the third one because of the you
can see why right it's this single
Lambda on the left hand side that just
makes it easy it's like already set up
for eliminating variables yeah so all I
have to do is go equation one take away
equation three now is this the only way
to solve it of course not just like with
normal simultaneous equations you could
have used equations one and two if you
wanted but this just seems like the
easiest way so make a choice that is um
simpler for you left hand side is one
what do we get on the right hand side
very good so subtracting uh two from
both sides I've got a value for mu and
now I just need to put that into an
appropriate equation what would you like
to substitute into
yeah
uh you you could choose any but I'm
going to be ultra lazy and I'm going to
put it into equation three can you see
why
what do you get on the right hand side
you get zero so I've got three plus
Lambda equals zero Lambda equals
negative three now this is really great
I've sold simultaneously is is that the
answer to the question
yeah that's right I actually need to
find the points
um and it is uh hopefully just just the
one if you ever think about it
um now what I need to do is again think
back to 2D right if you wanted to find
that point of intersection you would
usually have found an x value or a y
value and then what do you do with that
thing
um you would you would substitute it
into what one of the lines right and it
actually doesn't matter which line you
substitute into because if it's a point
of intersection it should be on both
lines right so I'm just going to take uh
one of these either uh what's the color
I haven't used yet here we go either
mute which I would substitute into the
second line because that's where it's
the variable or I would choose Lambda
and it would substitute that into the
first line which which do you want to do
yeah let's let's take the easier number
right so therefore I've got to
substitute that into the second line so
I'm going to do that substituting
in here so just noting I've got it's uh
let's see uh
the particular value of mu is minus one
so I'm just going to go minus maybe I'll
write 1 just for the sake of it and then
what is it six four five right
yeah like so
so what's that gonna give us well I'm
writing these as coordinates now right
so I'm going to switch from column form
into
um into coordinates seven take away one
Sorry Seven take away six is one and
then help me out
two and then
zero
that's our point of intersection now of
course just like um just like in
Pointer's intersection in 2D I could
verify this right how what might be a
way that I verified this
probably
yeah yeah I could I could do the the
other value right so I could go let's
let's go with say Lambda right
um obviously you don't need to do this
because I've already found a point of
substitution but this is the first time
you've done it so let's just make sure
we're doing it right Lambda equals
negative three so I'm gonna go what's
that four eight three right
four eight three I'm gonna take away
three lots of what is it one two one
okay
uh let's actually just for the sake of
it uh because we already know what the
answer should be right so I'm going to
write this in column form to be sure I'm
getting four take away three for X what
am I getting for y
a minus six eight minus six and then for
Z it's three take away three does that
match
yeah that looks pretty good right so
thumbs up okay so points of intersection
we can find those parallel lines we can
find those by looking at the direction
Vector remember the direction Vector is
the theme that's kind of equivalent to
gradient right you could find
perpendicular lines
um you can find these things called skew
lines do you know what a skew line is
have you heard that word before
skewed lines are in three dimensions and
they never intersect with each other
right so you know in two Dimensions
either your lines are parallel
or your Lions have to intersect
somewhere because if they're not
parallel they've got they've got to
collide eventually right but in three
dimensions that's not true right you can
have parallel lines in three dimensions
but you can also have non-parallel lines
that are never ever going to touch
forever and we call those skew lines
right so these are things you can do in
three dimensions that you can't do in
two so you're going to encounter some of
those as you go through the questions
there's a lot more to explore in Vector
equations of lines but this is all I
wanted to cover today as you can see by
the time does anyone have any clarifying
questions they want to ask for now just
on what we've covered today
my favorite thing is a real just a silly
notation thing yeah but they let me know
again come from a textbook but would you
ever use this like a subscript to call
them like R1 and R2 just to make oh yeah
yeah yeah absolutely in fact I think it
probably would have been better if the
textbook had done exactly that because
R1 R2 then it makes it unambiguous what
I'm substituting into later on so I do
think that's good practice because
um uh that way you can distinguish it
however I mean part of the precedent for
why the textbook has done this is
because if I told you in two Dimensions
hey here's here's one line and then
here's another you wouldn't be like oh
do I have to call one y one and Y2 you'd
be like no no they're just two different
lines right so I think they're just
following from that convention but
certainly I think just like you know why
did I why did I label these equations as
different things it was to make it
easier for me right so if it makes it
easier for you absolutely go for it and
I use subscripts all the time so thumbs
up to that